dans l'océan indien mayotte le smic va
faire un bond et le 1er juillet + 9 %
d'augmentation ce qu'il portera à 706
euros un petit mieux pour les mahorais
qui sont encore bien loin du smic
métropolitain
les syndicats avaient réclamé une hausse
de 28 % du smic le préfet a tranché ce
sera 9,1 pour cent d'augmentation
le salaire minimum à mayotte elle sera
donc de 647 euros à 706 euros brut
mensuel une hausse qui ne satisfait
personne le patronat estime que la
facture sera trop lourde beaucoup
d'entreprises sont en difficulté il y en
a même qui qui ont confirmé ces derniers
temps vous voyez tous les problèmes liés
les problèmes sociaux liés aux grèves
successives
empêchent beaucoup d'entreprises de
travailler les salariés quant à eux ne
sont pas plus satisfaits il juge la
hausse insuffisante pour compenser la
cherté de la vie sur place personne qui
habite haqqani qui fait l'aller-retour
pourtant pour venir travailler à
l'angola qui doit payer deux euros de
taxi par jour et qui mangent des
brochettes de trois héros ça lui fait à
15 euros par jour et 15 euros par jour
ça fait 330 euros ça fait la moitié de
son salaire
de partout
malgré cette hausse le smig mahorais
reste en effet largement inférieur à
celui de métropole 706 euros contre 1250
2 euros pour l'hexagone